[music]
>> Hey Ben, we're making money,
having fun, and I think we're making a
difference.
>> [music]
>> Are you guys good at this game?
>> She's a former professional poker
player.
>> She's she's odds on favorite.
>> You're a high stakes deal negotiator.
>> I'm going for the uh unhinged crazy
[__] tonight.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, actually these are like some
pretty good players here.
>> [music]
>> I played since I was 18, and people are
very good liars.
You win the game, you played well.
There's [music] no ethics.
>> It's literally a game that you are
incentivized to
>> not trust.
>> Like find each other's weaknesses. Yeah,
not trust. It's about the opposite.
>> All right, guys. Leave the friendship at
the bar. I need one of these. Thank you.
>> [laughter]
>> There you go.
Let's go kill some people. Come on.
>> [laughter]
>> I want to get it going. Thank you.
I'm now in charge. I'm the narrator.
Thank you for coming out. Very excited
to play another game of Mafia tonight. I
know
we've mostly all played together, but
there are a few new faces here. So, I'm
just going to go over the rules again
and the gameplay.
I'm holding 12 cards in my hand. I'm
going to give each one of you one card.
Do not reveal your card.
There going to be three jacks, and if
you're dealt a jack, you're the mafia.
There's one ace. If you're dealt the
ace, you are the angel.
There's one king, and if you're dealt a
king, you're the sheriff.
If you're not dealt one of these cards,
you're a townsperson.
The mafia's goal is to eliminate all
civilians. The townspeople's goal is to
expose and then eliminate all of the
mafia.
The angel's goal every night is to try
and save someone from the mafia,
and the sheriff gets to pick someone to
investigate.
If you have the sheriff and you point
someone out and they're the mafia, I'm
going to say, "Mafia." "Townsperson."
"Angel."
>> Mike, this seems kind of discriminatory
against Second Amendment rights
enthusiasts. You're saying just because
they have guns, they're a criminal
element?
>> [laughter]
>> Right, the sheriff probably has a gun as
well. We wouldn't have a mafia problem
if the townspeople had guns.
>> [laughter]
>> All right, guys.
Take one card, pass it down.
Then keep it face down.
Remember, you can lie about your role.
Say, "I'm the mafia, I'm the sheriff,
I'm the angel." You can lie about any of
those things. Mafia is a game of
deception and figuring out who is
deceiving you.
In a moment, I'm going to ask everybody
to go to sleep. Once everybody's eyes
are shut,
I'm going to ask the mafia to wake up.
The mafia will then open their eyes and
silently decide who to murder.
Then I'm going to ask the angel to wake
up and choose a player to save from the
mafia.
And after that, I'm going to ask the
sheriff to wake up to investigate
someone.
I'll ask everybody to wake up, and I'll
announce who was murdered. And the rest
of you will engage in an interrogation
of each other to figure it out who the
mafia is.
After the interrogation, two players are
going to be put on trial. They will each
get a chance to defend themselves before
the rest of the players vote on who
should be eliminated from the game.
The mafia win if they can eliminate
enough towns people until the mafia's
numbers exceed or are equal to all of
the towns people left in the game.
And the towns people win if they
eliminate all members of the mafia from
the game.
Let the games begin.
Everybody go to sleep.
Everybody go to sleep. Eyes down.
Heads down. Will the mafia please wake
up?
>> [music]
>> Will the mafia please uh point out who
you'd like to kill? Make it as clear as
possible.
Okay.
Go to sleep.
Will the angel please wake up?
Will the angel please select somebody to
save?
Angel, go to sleep.
Will the sheriff please wake up?
Who would you like to know about,
sheriff?
Go to sleep.
Everybody wake up.
Dylan was found in his basement riddled
with bullets.
Who did it?
Who killed Dylan?
>> Oh, that's a relief. So
>> [laughter]
>> Bye, Dylan.
>> Oh, Dylan.
>> He was riddled with bullets.
>> So, who's friends or knows Dylan well?
>> I I do.
And I've played mafia with him before,
and he's very good at this game.
So, somebody else who's played with him
knows that he's good and needed to take
him out.
>> a data point. So, I Brian and Trey both
reacted very
when it was announced that it was Dylan.
I'm not saying that's 100% proof, but it
was like a strong reaction that can
sometimes be a mafia over conversation.
>> though and they're really crazy in them.
So, maybe he was
>> Yeah, it could be totally
>> The reason I responded like that is
before the game, he literally wrote me a
note that said, "We can pass notes."
And then he went out and I was like,
"NO,
>> [laughter]
>> WE ARE NOT PASSING NOTES."
>> And did anyone else notice anything in
reactions or people's faces after Dylan
died?
>> Well, I think it's Josie.
>> Why me?
>> Uh cuz I watched when everyone looked at
their cards. And when you looked at your
card, you picked up the piece of paper
where you had written down the roles and
looked at that. Which makes me think
>> she's not doing it.
>> me think that you didn't have a three.
>> Well, I So, that could be she's a power
player.
>> Could be Could be a special, but also
then it was very quiet during the
selection of phase and I was listening
intently and there was movement in this
area.
>> So, I have to say cuz I sit right next
to her, I didn't hear anything, but I'm
totally deaf in my left ear. So,
>> [laughter]
>> I like the framing on looking at the at
the card.
The risk obviously with that line of
thinking is it if Josie is the sheriff
or the angel, then we're
screwed. I also will point out that when
I saw my card
>> You can say where you are. You can't say
your card.
>> Yeah, say I I was clocking it. It was
too obvious.
>> [laughter]
>> I wasn't allowed to say what my card
was, but I've just been drinking and I
couldn't even remember
>> [laughter]
>> what anything was.
>> Do you have a special role?
>> a 10 or something and been checking.
>> role I have is to be a little unhinged.
>> It's a data point.
>> a townsperson?
>> [gasps]
>> Yeah, I am. Yeah, totally.
Sam, what are you?
>> I'm a townsperson. What I was going to
say is it was interesting that Moxie
would take the risk of
saying that a novice player
clearly is like wants some special role.
But to say I think mafia.
>> Yeah, definitive statements like that
feels very mafia, right? Like a towns if
you're a towns person.
>> you're the most mafia, but
>> [laughter]
>> Just kind of coming out strong.
>> Way too much.
>> guys played against each other before?
>> No.
>> Yeah, I'll say I've played with Moxie
before.
This is his modus operandi, so he does
play like this. I'd say the pattern
matches.
>> Well, the other thing is is whatever
Brian says we should go with because he
can't die.
>> Yeah, thank [laughter] you Trey.
I've got a shield I've got a shield of
power.
>> Don't die. [laughter]
>> Brian, what is your strategy as a towns
person?
>> Get information. Ask questions that get
answers from people that give us signal
in particular ways. So, as an example,
Cyan, you haven't said anything yet.
>> I'm listening. I'm observing.
>> That's totally fair. Like what are you
listening and hearing? What are you
observing?
>> I'm just, you know, a villager and I am
learning relearning this game.
>> So, I need two people nominated for
trial. Yes.
Two people on trial, please. Write them
down on a card. Fold the card. We're
going to throw it in the bucket.
>> Both names on one card?
>> Both names on one card. Fold it. Two
names. Everybody has to vote for two
names.
Here, you can just take it and pass it
down. Just fold it.
>> Do we learn people's votes?
>> Uh you don't know the not these. You're
going to learn everybody's vote for who
dies.
>> But that's isn't that a huge part of it
of like seeing collusion and who agrees
with who?
>> From the founder of Signal, you sure
don't seem to care ABOUT PRIVACY.
>> [laughter]
>> SEEING SEEING WHO AGREES WITH WHO
AND like what the alliances are or
whatever is like
>> Are you going to sit on that one, Trey?
>> Yeah, yeah.
We'll see who they ultimately vote for.
>> [music]
>> Josie
and Ryan Biermeister
are on trial. All right, so I don't know
who was accused first. I think Josie.
You got 15 seconds to defend yourself,
not interrupted. Go.
>> I'm just saying, do I look guilty? I
think the person who chose me was just
because I look so crazy. [music]
>> Ryan.
>> Solid defense.
>> Well, I am obviously talking a lot of
strategy. If I were mafia, I'd probably
be a little more subtle and hiding. And
so I think about who is accusing me and
who voted for me. I'm 100% a town. If
you get rid of me, you get it rid of a
high information gathering player as a
villager who really wants to win.
>> Okay, everyone has to vote. You have one
vote. Raise your hand if you want to
kill Josie and keep it high. A very high
so people can see you.
>> [music]
>> 1 2 3 4 5. It's unanimous. Josie was
bopped in the head, dragged to the
center of the town square, and given the
electric chair. I'm sorry, Josie. You
are dead.
>> That was either really good or really
bad.
>> Like the mafia's their operating or is
it like a remotely operated electric
chair?
>> This is the town. The town did this. You
did this. You just did this.
>> So Josie
>> Okay, I understand now.
>> I thought your defense was excellent.
>> [laughter]
>> And now we find out who the mafia is. I
already have my bet, which is
>> Wait, do I get to tell you?
>> I think it's Ryan.
>> Oh, cuz I was mafia.
>> Oh, [__]
>> Everybody go to sleep.
Will the mafia please wake up and select
somebody who would like to die? I got to
see a straight pointer.
Will the mafia please go to sleep? Will
the angel please wake up and select
somebody who you would like to save?
Go to sleep.
Will the sheriff please wake up?
Select someone you would like to learn
about.
>> I was the [music] sheriff.
>> No, you weren't.
>> Yeah, it's going to be a fast game for
y'all.
>> Go to sleep.
Everybody wake up.
It was a quiet night.
>> Interesting.
Very interesting. So here's here's my
>> want to reveal themselves right now?
>> No, no, no, too early, too early,
too early, too early.
>> Nice try, Mafia.
>> Here's here's the analysis of this.
>> Oh my god, that is the most sus. I would
be all over that. It's the stupidest
thing to say.
>> I know.
>> What does Sam think?
>> If Moxie was right
and it was Josie
then the Mafia would want to kill the
person
that was onto them
which means that it was either Ryan or
Moxie who was just attempted to be
killed by the Mafia.
>> If you're a Mafia, who did you want to
kill last night? Who's the most likely
player that you're targeting?
>> I would say Moxie was the accuser of the
person got killed. Moxie would be the
most likely.
>> Most likely.
>> To be targeted by the Mafia.
>> In the first round of villager voting,
there's always three votes that are
usually coordinated against you. And so
the fact that Ryan was nominated means
like this is somebody that the Mafia
tried to vote off, basically.
>> Okay, Brian and Zion, like what are
what's some information we're missing?
Like
y'all are both a little quiet.
>> I I think it's Moxie. I still think so.
Um
>> What is that guy?
>> Because you're not a novice player. You
you picked up on a lot of like little
meta game stuff.
>> I mean I was listening and I heard
nothing and I think him being like I
heard some [__] is suspicious.
>> But he would have to feel so confident
and like I don't know.
>> I don't think he did hear some [__] I
think that's a way to That's what it
sounded like.
>> It's an intense early bluff. That's an
intense early lie.
>> Usually in the first game the Mafia are
quiet.
>> The quietest people are you guys. The
most distracting player has been you,
although you've stopped.
>> Um
>> Sorry, there's no upside to
>> Homer, distracting? What?
>> He's gone quiet, [laughter] have you
noticed?
>> Did she say distracted OR DISTRACTING?
>> WELL
>> SHE SAYS I'm really quiet. As she says
you're really distracting.
>> [laughter]
>> Who Who guys, who are we putting up?
>> So either that or that means it, you
know, now it's possible it's possible
that Joseph isn't playing well enough to
know whether she's telling the truth
about my nomination. Palmer.
>> Palmer? I don't
>> Based on what?
>> I should have just thrown Palmer under
the bus at the last second to try to get
him on the corner.
>> It's a good strategy.
>> She's just like you're a wild card, get
him out.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's do this fast, guys.
>> I would like to say [music]
if I get killed
I'd be heavily suspicious [music] of
Ryan B.
>> [laughter]
>> I think I'm Sam's going after me.
>> No, I I thought it was her, too. I
thought it was her, too.
>> If I get killed, I'd be highly
suspicious of Sam A.
>> [clears throat]
[laughter]
>> We've got our nominations.
Palmer
and Moxi are on trial.
Moxi, I think you were accused first, so
I'm going to give you 15 seconds first.
Remember, 15 seconds, no interruptions.
What's that?
>> What do you mean accused first?
>> I think you were in the last round. Am I
wrong? I heard accusations flying
around.
>> You just accused me in the diary.
>> Why are you micromanaging my You're I'm
in charge. You are going [laughter]
15 seconds, can't be interrupted. Did
you do it or not?
>> Okay, I am the angel. Last night, I
saved Ryan. [music]
Uh and nobody died, which means that
Ryan is for sure
>> [music]
>> not mafia.
At this point, I feel like we should
uh if the sheriff is still alive
>> Yeah, well, sheriff's gone. Sorry, bro.
>> Time. Time. Time. Time. Time. No, this
is not deliberation. This is a trial.
Palmer, you're up.
>> If that is true and that information
point is is is accurate, then almost all
of the prospecting around me potentially
being mafia is basically irrelevant
compared to everybody [music] else. Like
it made sense in that construct. That's
a completely new piece of information. I
know I've been nominated, but I do think
it'd be really dumb to kill [music] me
given that it's it's it's a completely
spurious nomination based on almost
nothing. People say when people say he's
too quiet. Also, [music]
he's talking too much.
It was a last-second toss of a name that
doesn't even make sense now.
All in favor of killing Moxi, please
raise your hand.
All in 1 2
>> I'm suspicious.
>> All in favor of killing Palmer?
Palmer's killed in the town
by a stoning
in the tradition of Shirley Jackson's
The Lottery.
You're dead.
>> Is that like an old person thing?
>> Everyone has read The Lottery.
>> What is that?
>> You guys have not read it Everyone
Everyone I thought everyone in America
had read The Lottery. I read it like
every single year in elementary school.
>> Shirley Jackson.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, yeah, the stoning.
>> Yes, it's called The Lottery.
>> Yeah, sorry, I phased out. That's
awesome.
>> Thank you.
>> Great reference.
>> The smartest one at this table
>> Enjoy your old person
>> understood the reference. Thank you.
>> Welcome.
>> Man, that's bull.
>> It was total [__] We agree.
>> Oh, man, I'm so sorry. [laughter]
How many crazy it was like based on
nothing?
>> Nothing. Everybody go to sleep.
Everybody go to sleep.
Will the mafia please wake up? Select
somebody
to die.
Go to sleep.
Will the angel please wake up and select
somebody to save?
Go to sleep.
Will the sheriff please wake up?
>> Is there a sheriff?
>> Select someone you would like to
learn about.
Got it? Go to sleep.
Everybody wake up.
The various pieces of Ryan Peterson were
found in five separate shipping
containers. Mafia killed him. Who did
it?
>> Okay.
I'm thinking Sam Sam's been coming after
me. You know that I'm a villager and you
saved me.
Um, the other people that I've thrown
out are kind of the quiet corner over
here.
>> There's two different like
game theory versions of this.
On the one hand
the mafia didn't try to kill Moxi.
Which means either that they were
playing a next level thing where they
were like if we kill Moxi it'll be
obvious that he was the angel.
>> The mafia's goal is to keep us as
confused as possible. If they kill off
Moxi now they're like basically
confirming our hypothesis.
>> That that's what I why I said there's
two game theory versions. It's like one
of them is like they're playing a
strategy game.
>> Assuming they're half decent then they
they shouldn't kill him. So
>> I am 100% town so I I don't know. I'm
choosing to believe your story because
you spoke of confidence about me.
Sam's been coming for me and this like
I've been like why are you two so quiet?
>> hasn't said anything.
>> I know. I know.
>> I've said a few things.
>> Yeah, wait.
>> I also just think that Cyan saying like
I I I haven't played in a long time.
Maybe that's true. But if that's not
true then it's extreme guilt. So I don't
know. I don't know. Maybe she actually
hasn't played in a long time.
>> who knows? I don't know you that well.
Is she naturally a shy person? You don't
seem like you are on Twitter.
>> I am.
>> [laughter]
>> Would the sheriff like to reveal
themselves now?
>> [__] No one's coming out then we
probably killed
>> Yeah.
>> the sheriff.
>> I think it was Justin.
>> Like at every at every round we're at
risk of losing the sheriff.
>> So the sheriff is the most valuable
player for
If the generally speaking if the sheriff
has discovered one mafia
>> They shouldn't speak up.
Trey.
>> Towns person. I've actually never been
mafia. Can you believe that? In like a
hundred games of mafia. The only time I
ever was he dealt the cards. I flipped
it over I was mafia.
>> a long speech.
>> No no no no no no [laughter] no no no.
>> This is a funny story.
>> And you misdealt and I had to turn it
back in.
>> do damage if you do? Speak [laughter] or
not.
>> We got to wrap this up. I need to hear
who's going up. Who's going up?
>> Yeah, here's here's my hypothesis. I
think
the mafia suspects would be Sam,
Tim, and Cyan.
That would be my guess. Otherwise and
I'm assuming in this that
you all came out hot because you felt
like you were towns person, you had
defensibility.
>> Yes.
>> And the three of you have been playing
it cool.
>> There's cookies, but I don't want to eat
one until Brian Johnson's looking me
right in the face.
>> [laughter]
>> We need nominations.
Write them down. Let's
do it as fast as we can.
Roxy, who do you think it is?
>> I think it's you and Cyan.
>> Wow, it's you and Cyan. Oh my god, Roxy
is so good.
>> Is he Is he mafia?
>> No.
>> We'll get a lot of information after
this.
>> If she If she turns out to be a bad guy,
like oof.
>> We have our nominees for trial.
>> Let's do Smooth. Cyan.
And Sam.
Bummer.
We've done it. 15 seconds a piece to
defend yourself.
>> Um I like observing people and I'm like
[music] to your point trying to learn
about everyone and I am default shy.
Trey can speak to this. We work
together.
Um and I speak when it's important. And
[music] so had I been the sheriff, I
would have spoken up. But I'm just a
villager. I run a little bakery down the
street.
>> Um [music] I think I am getting targeted
because uh likely accesses it is these
two. I don't think Cyan is probably a
mafia either, but uh
yeah, I think we're [music] going to
kill a towns person here either way uh
and then I would go after them quickly.
>> All in favor of killing Cyan?
>> I guess so. Sorry, I have to vote for
one.
>> [music]
>> And all in favor of killing Sam?
>> I don't I believe you, but
>> Sam gets the votes.
>> Sorry, Sam.
>> Sam was drawn and quartered by the town.
>> [laughter]
>> Sorry, man. You're dead.
Get on out of here. Not a
super-intelligent AI, that's a win in my
book.
>> [laughter]
>> You're dead?
I'm dead. I'm sorry.
>> All right, who is your guys?
>> Actually, now I think Cyan is probably
mafia.
Uh that just hit me as I was walking
out.
Possibly Trey?
>> You voted?
>> Yeah, I was too.
>> Everybody go to sleep. Townspeople go to
sleep.
Will the mafia please rise? Select
somebody you would like to murder.
Go to sleep.
Will the angel please rise and select
somebody he would like to save?
Go to sleep. Will the sheriff please
rise? Select somebody he would like to
learn about.
Go to sleep.
Everybody wake up.
Liv's charred remains were discovered at
the site of her burning man wedding.
>> [laughter]
>> The lady was burned.
The lady was burned. Who did it?
>> So, Liv voted for Cyan. I feel like Cyan
is still the mafia.
>> I was
possibly having a terrible read, but I
thought it was Palma.
Bad read?
>> Totally bad read. I'm a townsperson.
>> But masterfully steered the group. I was
suggested for no reason.
>> In the favor of the mafia?
>> No, no, no. Like, you got everyone to
think it was him masterfully.
>> Yeah.
>> So, at what point
does someone claiming to be the angel
continue to survive?
>> My understanding of the rules is that
you just can't save the same person
twice in a row. Including yourself.
Including yourself, right? But that
means that it's not clear to the mafia
whether
I can save myself on any given night or
not. And I'm highly incentivized to save
myself.
>> saying the mafia may have missed it.
That they
>> Well, no, because you said you saved
Ryan and then the next time you saved
was the next time you saved.
>> Like it's not like no one died one
night.
>> No one's been saved since he revealed
that.
>> What night did he save her? What night
did he save her?
>> Two. That's what I'm saying is like he
he definitely saved himself on the third
night because he knew he just revealed
that he was mafia or he was an angel.
>> Tell us who you saved in the past. What
was your order?
>> I've saved myself twice and you once.
>> What about the other two times?
>> Then there's one more time and I can't
reveal that cuz that was last night.
>> But here's the thing is I I've played
with Moxy before. So it I could be I
could be surprised.
>> If he's mafia
>> I could be very I could be surprised,
but I don't think he's mafia. Mafia, if
you [__] if you [__] me Moxy on this
>> I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. I can't I'm
an angel. I I revealed the fact that I
was an angel very early in the game and
not a single other person here was like
actually I am an angel.
>> Yeah, it was valid.
>> My best hunch is that if we kill Cyan
now, we win the game. But we'll find
out.
>> this is how you say this is basically
>> I agree with Cyan. It's the highest
probability vote.
>> What?
>> I think Moxy is a higher probability
vote. We have so little information on
Cyan.
>> I know. Well, we do know that she Liv
Why did Liv just get killed?
Liv was the only one voting for her.
>> I I feel like we do Cyan and Moxy in
head-to-head it, right?
All right guys, nominations.
>> with that.
>> Why are Tim and Travieon suspicion?
[music]
>> I agree with that.
>> [laughter]
>> Trial.
Cyan.
And Brian.
Cyan, you have 15 seconds to defend
yourself.
>> Oh, Brian.
>> Uh
again, [music]
I am not super verbal, and I still think
it's Moxie because the whole angel thing
doesn't make a whole lot of sense.
And
um
>> [music]
>> I would say that. I would say I'm an
angel, and
it's a very good strategy.
But
and it could be you. You've been very
quiet.
>> I voted for Brian first round.
>> I wrote the immortal.
>> [laughter]
>> I voted for Brian also.
>> All right. Brian, you're up.
>> That makes so much sense. The mafia I
got just enough votes from the mafia
because my accusations were pointed. I
said I said Moxie was not, Trey was not.
Brian, I don't think you are.
I think Tim and Cyan are the most sus. I
think Cyan is the most. So, it makes
[music] sense that they would target me,
and I would then trip on the on the vote
count. But, it makes no sense why I'd be
mafia.
>> The trial is concluded. All in favor of
killing Cyan, raise your hand.
>> It's so annoying cuz they're [music]
>> All in favor of Well, killing Brian,
raise your hand.
Cyan was strapped into a pair of cement
boots and kicked into the town lake.
She's dead.
>> Uh
>> Everybody go to sleep.
>> And the game is continuing, dammit.
>> Oh, [laughter] and the
>> Welcome. Welcome.
>> You killed me.
>> I know. I'm sorry. I know. I'm so sorry.
>> Do you like how you were executed by the
government?
>> Yes.
>> By having your concrete boots and thrown
off of a pier?
>> Yes.
>> Will the mafia please rise?
Select somebody who you would like to
die.
Go to sleep.
Will the angel please wake up and select
somebody who you would like to save.
Go to sleep.
Sheriff, please wake up.
Select someone you would like to learn
about.
Go to sleep.
>> [music]
>> Everybody wake up.
Sadly,
Ryan Johnson did in fact die.
>> [laughter]
>> Woah.
>> Who did it?
>> Trey can take us home.
>> I don't know, actually.
>> I think he can.
>> I don't know about that. I think I think
he's going to lose this round, actually.
>> So, the game's still going on.
>> I am so annoyed.
>> Right. One mafia.
>> How is it possible that these random
people are dying
and Moxie doesn't even get nominated?
>> it's him. Because I I've been trusting
you and he just randomly is accusing you
and like I feel like I feel like you
cleared your name pretty well.
>> I didn't find out how I died, though.
Yeah.
>> What's your best guess? Who do you think
is mafia?
>> Um I'd say Trey.
>> Tim.
>> Final answer?
>> Trey.
>> Trey, why are you like what have you
done to How are you not mafia? Tell us
your defense, like.
>> I've I've been like outing all the
people that I I think are mafia that
we've been killing. I've been on your
side for every single game.
>> You have. Like who do you think the
other two mafia were?
>> My best guess I'm pretty suspicious of
Cyan. I think Cyan was probably mafia.
I
Sam maybe was mafia.
>> But Moxie feels like he's just out
playing us.
>> I agree. So, Moxie,
is there a chance that Moxie lied and
he's a mafia and he pretended to so that
you'd be on you'd be on his side now,
even though
>> And he does know I'm town if he's mafia,
right?
>> Right. If he was doing something clever
and pretending to be angel, so I feel
like you're automatically innocent here.
>> I I just don't
>> And so therefore it's one of them and I
feel like we should kick off Moxie and
then if and then we still have another
chance and kick off him.
>> You've had another chance.
>> it. We need names, guys. it. We have to
get this right.
We have to put some names up. I need
nominees.
>> I mean, what's your theory? Tell me your
name.
>> for sure that you're a villager and I
know for sure that I am a villager. So,
in my mind, I'm just trying to decide is
it Tim or Trey?
>> Well, what's your theory?
>> And
I don't know.
>> You just lost my trust. I can't explain
why.
>> Nominations, please.
>> Wait, no.
>> Write them down.
>> Tell me why.
>> know.
>> Write them down. You keep talking like
you're right or you're wrong.
>> And in my mind, it's like Trey is doing
this
just to every round.
>> I put myself on the list because I am
that convinced that Muxy
>> [music]
>> is mafia. Put me on trial, please. This
is [laughter] absurd.
>> I'm not mafia.
>> I don't know him well enough to know
what that means. Like, that was
convincing, but like maybe he just does
that kind of [__]
>> No, I I This is genuine passion and
>> He does seem very upset. I think he's
sad now cuz he blew it after all this
great play and then at the very end.
>> that's tripping me out is that
you used logic to agree with my position
that me and Ryan [music] are
>> We have a
>> sound. And then just
in in instant at the just before voting,
you're like, "It's Muxy."
>> Trey and Muxy are on trial. Trey, you
got 15 seconds uninterrupted.
>> [music]
>> Guess who else can save themselves other
than the angel? The mafia. The mafia
can't kill themselves.
>> Yes.
>> He keeps like deflecting, deflecting,
deflecting, but the reality is that he
claimed he was the angel. It's been
three turns. No one has killed him. He
keeps redirecting to all of these other
things. It's like, "Guys, he's very good
at this. It's obvious he's very good at
this."
>> So, this this is like a real
performance. This is
>> This is a good argument because he
hasn't saved anybody since Heather,
right?
>> Muxy, 15 seconds.
>> Uh
it's not me. I am the angel. I revealed
myself on the second round. Uh I did
that in a moment where there's only one
other person out. If I were mafia,
[music] I would have had to gamble that
that person was the angel. Not a single
other person spoke up and was [music]
like, "Wait, I spoke up. I'm the angel."
I think the reason that I'm still alive
is because the mafia want to get
somebody every night. And [music] the uh
there's
there's at least a 50% probability that
if they choose me that I have saved
myself on that night. And so they risk
that. And then number two is that they
get the ability to say every day, "Why
is Moxy still alive, god damn it? It's
so suspicious."
>> Trey, you get a 5-second rebuttal.
>> I don't think I have to fill any more
time than Moxy just did in his crazy
defense.
>> Okay.
There are four of you, which do the
math. This is the last vote of the game.
All in favor of killing Trey, raise your
hand.
>> If you're mafia, I hate you.
>> I I'm I'm not and I'm going to vote
Moxy.
>> Dude, dude, it is
>> All in favor of
>> I 100%
>> All in favor of killing Moxy, raise your
hand. Guys, we need votes.
We need votes. We have to vote.
>> to We We can win this right now. I am
for sure absolutely I am not the mafia.
And no.
>> Moxy is dead. Moxy was kicked into a vat
of piranhas AND THE MAFIA WINS.
>> [screaming]
>> LET'S GO!
LET'S GO!
>> [screaming]
[cheering]
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> WHY DID YOU LIE TO ME? YOU SAID YOU
HADN'T
PLAYED BEFORE. SO ARE YOU VERSION
>> OH, YOU'RE
KIDDING ME.
>> I knew it. Absolutely.
>> I cannot believe a word you said. Again.
>> I cannot believe this. THAT'S
>> WE [__] UP.
>> HOW DID he do that?
>> I cannot believe this [__]
>> Moxy, I'm so sorry.
>> That did not go how I thought it would
go.
>> I cannot
>> I don't know why you were still
alive.
>> How could you not?
>> I believed in you.
>> HOW COULD YOU NOT?
>> I I COULDN'T GET OVER IT.
>> BECAUSE HE WAS SO HE was so convincing.
>> And your face.
>> But you being alive was actually But
they just outplayed us on that.
They just outplayed you.
>> That was a good play.
>> This is an excellent mafia move. He is
masterful.
If I was an innocent villager and
somebody was just like, "I know you're
mafia." I would lose my [__] [__]
>> If you get this wrong,
we're done.
>> I'm the town drunk. I'm just going to
keep drinking.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.